I love this guy and I don't care who
knows it his show could you say our show
follows his on YouTube sure why not yeah
of course his show precedes ours on
YouTube because the number of people
that show up on our chat room I'm
talking about vitamins and whatever Pat
McAfee had just talked about well right
now everyone in the chat is just typing
a Jayhawk show with a Jayhawk
and his show is also on Westwood one and
he's one of my favorite people and I'm
like let us finish up our draft week on
NBCSN with this man he is Pat McAfee how
are you pat rich I'm fantastic every
time I get a chance to chat with you and
Chris and everybody over is Dell to fo
still there the whole corner highlight
of it is the highlight of my day thanks
for having me on this beautiful
feel-good Friday
Patrick walk me through how you feel
Aaron Rodgers feels right now what's he
thinking do you think right now you know
I'm not sure how he feels he was on our
raft super special last night with mr.
AJ Hawk myself and the boys and he I
think was enjoying the hell out of
himself he was laughing he had his big
old beard he had his hair slicked back
the denim jacket on I think he was very
excited for who the Packers were going
to pick he mentioned in reference al
there hasn't been a skilled player
drafted by the Packers in 15 years so
that would be cool but also if the
defensive player gets picked it's all
good he likes where teams at and then
all of a sudden out of nowhere I think
the entire world
the dress was kind of boring there was a
couple of selections of wide receivers
that nobody expected before the other
person Judy not going first I think was
surprising your boy mike Mayock me to
play there but then off the top rope the
Green Bay Packers come in and do
something that nobody expected him to be
frank I think was a very stupid draft
choice and if I was Aaron Rodgers that
desire confused with four years left on
my contract we're one game away from the
Super Bowl last year we gave up a
hundred and eighty six yards before
contact against the San Francisco 49ers
we have a lot of holes on our team let's
go try to win a Super Bowl but you said
here we are drafting a backup
quarterback and this is no offense to
Jordan love but I feel like if I'm Aaron
Rodgers I would be mightily pissed off
yeah especially again you know
Pete myself that I've said before for
for the sake of our conversation here
Pat is the 49ers the team that you know
who most art is still running as the
phrase that Joel clot used before our
conversation here on the show that team
went from the spot behind where the
Packers originally were to the spot in
front of where the Packers eventually
moved up to take a receiver for their
for their quarterback Tom Brady's new
team moved up a spot to get a protector
for Tom and the Packers who were one
game away from the Super Bowl took
somebody who is Jay Glazer told me on
our live stream on NFL Draft Athan
laughs last night does not get them any
closer to the Super Bowl they were one
game away from the Super Bowl he does
not get them zero games away it's got to
be tough think about this there's not a
lot of humans that you can put into the
same air as Aaron Rodgers right Tom
Brady Drew Brees Aaron Rodgers those are
probably the three guys that you can
compare right now Aaron Rodgers has four
years left on his contract right Drew
Brees has a two-year deal he just signed
him was hurt last year Tom Brady signs a
two-year deal did you see the Buccaneers
draft a backup quarterback or the future
of the franchise No did you see the
Saints do that no instead on the
complete opposite side they drafted to
protect their guy because they know that
they got a guy I do don't understand how
this plays out how this works and I
understand there's some buffoons that
have to get on TV and defend the pick
but in my eyes I don't think this is
ever gonna look good I just don't know
why you want to make Aaron Rodgers hate
their organization I don't know why you
don't want to protect Aaron Rodgers and
I don't know why you don't get them a
weapon or two or maybe you lose Martinez
on the defensive side of the ball
Patrick Queen is sitting there it just
feels like this is a very in-depth
decision and I don't know how they're
gonna spin this for people to think it's
a good idea but it's just dumb rich I
don't get it's just dumb I think Pat
McAfee of the Pat McAfee show on radio
also podcasts YouTube right here on the
Rich Eisen show did you like the tua pic
by the Dolphins over Herbert what do you
think of that one Pat I know that I
could never listen to another word that
Tannenbaum says I know that Tannenbaum
former general manager that doesn't
allegedly friends with the rocks family
the owner of the dolphins he goes on get
up like a week and a half ago in says
that it would be irresponsible to take
tua in the top ten and that might have
been a kamikaze mission sent by the
dolphins but you say that on the
internet or not TV but the narrative
became that to his injury-prone who was
our top five picks everybody had him
tanking going down the draft boards and
then there we are
number five dolphins get their guy that
we all thought they're going to take all
along I like to a behind Fitzpatrick
that guys played for forty two NFL teams
and franchises he's a smart guy be
flowed almost fought arrest last year I
mean I just think that is a great team
on the rise especially in the AFC East
to just lock Tom Brady and Gronkowski I
like what the Dolphins did yesterday not
just with that pick
but with their other two as well by the
way I never went for the head fake with
anything that I heard about the Dolphins
not being into tour that they were into
Herbert that they were trading up for a
tackle what mr. t is Francesa refers to
Tannenbaum in New York City is the Pope
would call him on WFAN that whatever
anyone who's saying I didn't I called it
the Keyser söze of smokescreens it was
the it was the greatest had ever been
and now poof it's gone now it's gone
into as though that's the difference
between you and me that's why you're a
legend and that's why I'm very new in
the game i bought it i painted Baum win
lie saying if I want to get on
television and lie like that this guy is
trying to set something up for the
Dolphins family so that whenever they
don't draft to what everybody can expect
it turns out mr. t complete don't listen
to work ever again and that's how I feel
well Pat I mean these are could be not
mutually exclusive I mean that the the
Dolphins could have been smoke screening
and Tannenbaum could think that that it
would be derelict of duty to take two in
the top ten could very well be that I
mean it's entirely possible because
again an evaluator doesn't get their
their hands on somebody with the medical
staff that's the issue I just think it
was worth it it's worth every single
second you want to put Fannie's in the
seats at Hard Rock you
you have people who had a front row seat
to to his Alabama tenure you're an SEC
country go ahead and do it I love it
well remember the Dolphins less than a
year ago everybody said they were
tanking for two they traded out tons old
who has the greatest lungs in the
history of the NFL they got rid of Kenny
Stills they're making all these plays
but everybody forgot that when you have
Ryan Fitzpatrick at quarterback the man
who has a brain from Harvard a heart of
a plumber he's gonna win games all by
himself and be flow the same type of
thing you bringing towel Vannoy they
signed the wide receiver to a long-term
deal now you have your quarterback of
the future things are looking very very
much like they're on the upswing for the
Dolphins and it hasn't been like that
for a long I love brains of a Harvard
man heart of a plumber that is Ryan
Fitzpatrick the anti-tank quarterback
there was no tanking in that man there's
only windows that he shouldn't throw
into that's about it he comes to Ryan
and he is way too smart to be doing the
things that he does anomaly 9 games
whether you like it or not McAfee here
on the Rich Eisen show so again I was in
the NFL Draft a thon chat room all night
long I was keeping an eye on the on the
linear television broadcast which home
draft setup that you saw last night do
you think is the one seed if we were to
put it in the bracket which is which is
advancing which is your favorite from
last night you sorry let's talk about a
couple years we have to do if we're
gonna do this Bill Belichick and man
talk it with his kitchen table
completely bare in the wall is empty in
the windows clothes just love that
wouldn't expected anything else from
Bill Belichick then I heard you guys
talking before I got on here Kliff
Kingsbury in the middle of the desert in
Arizona has a grotto type thing with a
bonfire in the ground with an ax he
looked like he was fresh out of some
cocaine drug lord movie but the person
and you mentioned it and I mentioned I
think we're on the same page if you were
doing a draft that revolves around Wi-Fi
in most people's Wi-Fi plugged into
their house
you choose to do it on a 250 million
dollar super yacht that called Bravo
Eugenia from Miami you are a legend you
are AG in making everybody Google the
yacht that he's on so everybody knows
what Jerry Jones got especially with the
rumors coming out that he told his
scouting Department not to interrupt him
I mean that is just the winner of the
night and they got a damn good player in
Sidi lamp I'll just tell you this Pat
man you know when it comes to it you
knew with all the home setups that there
would have to be somebody behind the
scenes off-camera that you could
potentially see in a glass window doing
something what's going the Vrabel
situation with what's going on in the
house where you know look the Titans
were number two in the AFC when it was
all said and done we all know that but
it looks like something's going on Pat
do you have any thoughts on that subject
you know and I do think I did not give
were able enough justice there and I run
down of Belichick Kliff Kingsbury in
Jerry Jones on a super yacht and that is
100% true statement what you're saying
there
he's one kid with the mullet over his
left shoulder yeah the other kid and
they Teletubby onesies over his right
shoulder
his daughter sitting Native American
style on a chair and then in the
reflection it appears to be another kid
you know taking a grumpy and then he has
a massive whipper in that house I mean
just a hog maybe a half a tin in his
face and he spits immediately upon
coming on camera
I think Bray Bowl is a guy that I would
want to play for a guy that I would like
to drink beers with and I think the
family is electric as well and I guess
the world Electric oh my gosh man
anything else from the draft coverage I
may have missed that you you want to
pound the table for that you saw that
I'm missing from last night Pat henry
rugs the third okay there was two other
Henry rug Jews before him him putting on
his robe
Old Spice robes immediately upon getting
drafted with a banner over his head
saying his name I think that potentially
takes the cake for my favorite moment of
a draft prospect but also lets not
undersell CV Lam getting his phone taken
from him from his girlfriend and then
also that offensive lineman's mom who
decodes the often fun girlfriend to get
the hell out of the camera was awesome
and I can't wait for the rest of the
dress you see McKay beckons father was
bigger than he is Pat yeah yeah he's a
DTAC 'el that's a guy wish the Colts
would sign next to the poor's Buckner
that would be great in that big gray
shirt he looked like he could get out on
a field and clog up some holes if he had
to it I think this year the draft I
thought you guys are gonna have a lot of
problems over there at the NFL to be
honest with you because we deal with the
internet technology on a daily basis
here as are you with YouTube and
everything I think it was very well done
by everybody including Roger Goodell
with a costume change the middle of that
thing and then hyping up the zoom crowd
every single time I really think it was
well done top to bottom it was man and
again Pat would you want to you want to
join the the draft it's on live tonight
I'm gonna book you right now if you're
free if you're up for wanting to do that
you'll be I saw that guest list you got
to star-studded for me that's not true
come on now you got to line up you could
crack a lot of point last night we were
live McAfee and Hawk and you guys were
lives yes I think you had Kevin Hart
there's a walk
DJ Khaled Tom Brady on there at one
point and it was me and a Jayhawk
smoking vitamins in cigars we didn't
have the rock it was stray but you know
he's still a superhero in his own right
but all right before I let you go Pat
everybody wants to play for Brady or
with him Gronk's coming back what about
you
pack or you got any thoughts about
coming out of retirement maybe kickin
some balls for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
I've been hearing some some noise from
your world what do you think I'd be
completely lying if I said I didn't go
to my backyard and start punting balls
this week I mean whenever you see
Gronkowski come out of retirement and I
got a lot of friends that are older and
free agents that I get along with very
well that are calling me up saying hey
let's go down to Tampa let's try to get
a pinky ring Super Bowl ring I mean
there is definitely some thought on
Mayan I'm gonna have to lose about
thirty pounds because when I was putting
this week my thigh kept hitting my gut
which is a problem but it is nice to
know that Obama ball I just have to
figure out whether or not I can do it
for the duration because it's been a
couple years here since I've really got
on a workout schedule but I would be
lying if I said I did not see if I could
go and try and make that Buccaneers team
you know what Pat and I would root i
would root for that because again you
and Gronk in Florida together for
Aaron's and sign me up Pat sigh me all
the way up for that a million remember
you gotta remember clyde christensen
quarterback coach jeff used to be a good
call yeah tom moore they're all there
Bruce all of them those are all my
people down there literally all my
people down there and it feels like they
want to win - they're not drafting
backup quarterbacks whenever they have a
show potentially in the draft way to
bring it full circle but let's uh one
last question for you before I send you
on of the day let's let's let's spin
forward to tonight and and tomorrow
who's the first punter going give me the
punter give me the punter break down who
who is gonna get drafted Pat for the
brand I have no idea punter wise there's
a couple guys that kind of have a
similar leg but looks old hot rod
respect suspect out of Georgia they get
picked up within the next day or so okay
I think there's a couple places that
need a kicker and I think old
Blankenship down there who's had a rap
song with offset and has kicked in SEC
Championships and national championships
is going to be the first guy off the
board
you the man love you everybody check out
Pat show YouTube is pod everything that
Pat is the churning out it's all
fantastic I love being part of it let me
know when I can Pat rich we love you man
not everything's fantastic we have some
misses but we'll hit a home run every
once in a while okay you're the greatest
Cheers stay safe over there I heard you
going off about people judging gentleman
for putting the mask on instead of his
thing right
it was weird yeah he's but he's got
somebody in his in his from his staff
that's right there he is vulnerable he's
a guy who's coming off of being sick
last year that's what I'm saying I know
I know but he literally we saw him
without the mask in that backdrop looks
like he had a tiny little photo and then
they cut back to him he looks like
banging all of a sudden I mean it came
out of nowhere but I agree I think
safety first I'm on your side there but
I do believe it kind of hit hit us from
the side there whenever he popped back
in with his mask on you take your scare
your whole family Pat be well stay out
everybody you got it cheers rich we met
you out here bub right back at you
that's Pat McAfee at Pat McAfee show on
Twitter it's a must father god that's so
funny he cracks me up me and Pat always
has always has hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here